bonjour alors le château de gizo vous le
voyez juste derrière moi il est composé
d'une partie médiévale et aussi d'une
partie renaissance il a en fait au début
appartenu à la famille dubé laisser la
famille du poète du célèbre poète qui
était avec ronsard pour la pléiade alors
aujourd'hui il appartient à la famille
de la faune et ça depuis 10 786 vous
allez voir que ce château est renommé
notamment pour sa galerie de peintures
murales
on la découvre tout de suite
[Musique]
le château de ge a appartenu au du
bellay la famille du poète de la pléiade
pendant plus de 300 ans de la période
renaissance
il reste deux trésors les galeries de
peinture celle du roi a été initiée par
marie d'yvetot
l'épousé de rené dubé les au début du
xviie siècle elle va faire venir entre
500 et 700 10 dans cette galerie des
professionnels italiens pour réaliser
sur boiseries l'ensemble des peintures
que vous voyez dans cette dans cette
galerie donc sur les murs sur le plafond
également et la grande cheminée
mythologie grecque bouquet de fleurs
agrémenté de tulipes très recherchée au
xviie siècle
l'état de conservation de ses boiseries
est exceptionnel grâce à l'intuition nez
du bébé au moment de la révolution
la famille qui habitait les lieux à
cette époque a craint du coût des
dégradations et a fait construire avec
les villageois de gizo un second mur en
torchis devant l'ensemble des murs est
en dessous du plafond donc pour protéger
les boiseries et on a fini par oublier
qu'il y avait un torchis dans cette
salle vers 1890 l'arrière grand père de
monsieur de la faune avait 8 ans et
jouer dans cette salle et a percé le
torchis avec sa toupie et donc quand ils
ont retiré le torch il s'avère que les
boiseries était encore en très bon état
un peu plus loin la salle des châteaux
et ses 400 m² de peintures murales
est-ce que vous reconnaissez le château
ici bientôt qui est à l'est de la région
parisienne
oui exactement c'est le château de
vincennes en fait qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui toujours le donjon médiéval
et la chapelle qui sont toujours debout
versailles fontainebleau chambord cette
galerie a été réalisée par une école de
peinture à la fin du xviie siècle
et voici à quoi elle ressemblait en 2014
contrairement à la salle françois 1er
elle n'avait pas été protégé contre les
assauts du temps il a fallu six ans de
restauration et 500000 euros pour
obtenir la galerie que vous pouvez
visiter aujourd'hui je trouve ça beau je
trouve ça sympa que les personnes
viennent ici avant pour refaire ses
tableaux ben moi franchement je trouve
que ça a été bien réalisé ils ont fait
une belle perspective au niveau du
château
mon préféré franchement c'est le château
de vincennes qui est derrière
je trouve qu'ils ont bien réalisé par
contre un problème avec les lapins avec
la perspective qui semble plus gros
qu'un cheval liseuse est l'un des plus
grand château habité de la région centre
c'est certainement aussi ce qui séduit
ses onze mille visiteurs chaque année
outre la galerie avec ses peintures
murales la particularité du château de
gizeh c'est qu'il est habité par la même
famille depuis 250 ans depuis 10 786
c'est la famille de la faune ici
aujourd'hui vivent trois générations et
nous retrouvons le propriétaire du
château monsieur de la faune bonjour
bonjour enchanterait alors dites moi
vous vous avez exposé vos photos de
famille au milieu de la galerie du roi
sait pas comment passer d'abord notre
salon c'est là où on prend l'apéritif
avec les copains ceux là où on prend
l'apéritif en pleine saison estivale
quand il fait beau
avec les autres que nous recevons c'est
vrai qu'en hiver on se rapatrie dans une
pièce un peu plus petit et plus chaud
fable mais c'est d'abord notre salon la
galerie françois 1er françois 1er il
vient plus depuis très longtemps pour
que voilà vous l'aurez compris la notion
de vie privée au château 10 n existe pas
vraiment d'ailleurs on va aller voir les
appartements de cette famille de la
faune allez-y rentrée asseyez-vous alors
dites moi on est où ici
eh bien on est dans sein de salon
familiaux mais en même temps c'est la
pièce où ont lieu les dîners des tables
d'hôtes et des petits déjeuners des
tables d'hôtes gouaille est pour nous
l'un et l'autre se côtoient sans aucune
difficulté
alors comment vous faites pour financer
tout ça pour restaurer tout ça on a la
chance d'être très bien accompagné pour
des travaux très spécifiques comme la
galerie que vous avez vu par la drac les
monuments historiques
mais pour des travaux qu'on ne peut pas
assumer avec les revenus de la famille
vient nous avons la chance d'être
entouré également par le mécénat
participatif qui nous permet de réaliser
certaines choses et pour le reste il
faut relever les manches s'y mettre
soi-même et et avoir des très bons
artisans qui vous conseille et vous
entourent merci beaucoup monsieur de la
faune merci nous avoir accueillis chez
vous ou pas chez vous faire maintenant
c'est plus vraiment un trailer demain on
ira au château de montpoupon a serré la
ronde toujours en indre et loire vous
allez voir c'est un haut lieu de la
chasse à courre à demain